i want to ask you about the golden arm
because i'm a big samurai i'm a big sam
rainey fan
i know what happened with the viral clip
but i'm curious from your perspective
with that clip that goes out there
it almost the whole episode overall
almost felt like a little bit of an
in-joke in a very classic sam raimi
style and that clip goes viral
without the ending so do you feel like
it was kind of a situation of people
i don't know getting the joke but not
getting the punchline
i don't think they got the joke like it
was i think that was the most
frustrating part about it because
you would know as a fan of sam raimi i
mean the huge reason to do this project
i had this meeting with sam raimi
having been familiar with his work from
afar
you fall in love with the man instantly
the passion that he has for this
practical horror which is not
necessarily a genre that i would have
been attracted to
is infectious it's so exciting i mean it
and it was like that on set it was one
of the most
fun experiences i've ever had and you
you know
you have this experience of someone like
sam raimi going more blood more blood
cannons let me pour the blood all over
you
and and you know you know it's camp it's
it's classic
sam raimi camp and so it was kind of a
bummer for a project that i think very
much
was what it set out to be for this more
serious part of the the the show
to go viral so that people could rip it
out of that context that truthfully
can bring people so much joy